strapping everyone for the most exciting
Shake of this Series has to offer
through the same material we explored
what it means to be true to who you are
in the face of adversity examining the
themes of nature versus nurture in one
of the best clashes I've ever seen
following that we press forth onto the
stars above journey to Namek where we
encountered the terrifying Frieza there
the Saiyan arcs themes were pushed to
their natural breaking points forcing
Goku out of his comfort zone and into
yet unexplored Waters wielding a
terrifying power against a seemingly
insurmountable evil one that left the
future of the series in a very uncertain
position however this week is different
while building once again off of the
Bedrock story established in the last
two arcs this time we are revisiting the
themes of expectations versus reality in
what is considered to be the best
stretch of story there's a long and
winding tale has by many delivering
alongside some of the most recognizable
fights in the series offering snapshots
in history moments in time that to this
day surface over and over again in pop
culture at the heart of this narrative
is a tale that explores what it truly
means to appreciate life and the tall
one with great power must pay in order
to protect it there's no sense in
delaying this any further this is what
many of you have been waiting for this
is simply Akira toriyama's inspirational
epic the cell Saga
come here
[Music]
to tell you the truth having not read
through this material in quite some time
from the moment this Arc kicks off I was
taken aback by quite a few aspects of
the story that felt I don't know
different to how I remembered it and
through that I gained a new appreciation
for the story beyond the widely
understood troubles it faced creatively
early on a newfound appreciation which
began with act one
foreign
given the story Akira Toriyama wants to
tell in this material I think this is
perhaps the most clever way to go about
it from the very moment this Arc kicks
off the connective tissue that
establishes a relationship between this
and the previous Arc sets in motion what
ultimately becomes the single biggest
misdirection this Arc sets out to
accomplish and that misdirection is
Son Goku right from the get-go we are
anticipating Goku's return as
established by the namekian dragon our
heads are filled with questions like
where is he why didn't he come back and
moreover once Frieza makes his presence
felt as he approaches Earth for his
revenge we are overcome by this thought
that we can't do this without him
whether you're looking at the
belligerent and egotistical Vegeta or
the unsure Sun Gohan you can see on
their faces the look of Despair when
they realize the scope of the foe they
have to defend against
foreign
[Music]
foreign to say that I was blown away by
this debut of trunks would be an
understatement of the highest magnitude
having come off the back of what I
consider to be the most fun and
impressive Arc conclusion thus far in
Goku vs Frieza which brandished a
transformation I had obsessed with ever
since laying my eyes on it here trunks
arrives out of nowhere in all of his
Super Saiyan Majesty much to the Chagrin
of a certain Prince what a phenomenal
way to re-establish the stakes he's
about to reveal to Our Heroes the
villain of the previous Arc dispatched
in an instant by this powerful Warrior
only to then reveal the horror that
awaits was too much for even him to
handle it completely and utterly uproots
any sense of balance we as an audience
had about the top of the power chain
here but the line Akira Toriyama decided
to walk with trunks is a fascinating one
even if you ignore this with an intro
and design like this one might think
he's the de facto leader of this Arc and
while he is in some respects by virtue
of him bringing the call to action to
light for Our Hero's dancer he's
revealed to be incredibly naive and
ill-prepared for pretty much every
aspect of this Mission he's on the
moment we meet trunks he's placed on
this pedestal the likes of which he'll
never fully scale again until the very
very end of this Arc and maybe not even
then while he is a Super Saiyan and yes
while he is on some level a capable
fighter seen through his comfortable
dismantling of Frieza himself he's also
a child of no more than 17 years
[Music]
if it wasn't clear I think this scene is
spectacular from a narrative standpoint
after having declared himself stronger
than Goku to Frieza in a moment that
should have been another impressive
notch on the young trunks's belt the
fact that he's actually from the future
the reveal of this fact is instead
nestled in a moment that exposes his
naivety and inexperience and these are
two elements two attributes of his
makeup that end up defining his
character in this Arc a character that's
so feverishly wants and needs to be a
hero in spite of these drawbacks to his
character having come to this timeline
for the sole purpose of giving Goku his
heart medicine and to alert everyone of
the impending Android threat due to
Goku's supposed lateness trunks
additionally decides to step in to
defeat Frieza himself ultimately
changing the trajectory of this timeline
however and this is what makes this
scene impressive to me Goku wasn't
actually three hours away he could have
an absolutely would have being there in
an instant if he needed to which he was
destined to thanks to his acquisition of
another impressive technique
teleportation or otherwise known as
Instant Transmission and so in this
first panel that all but explicitly
tells us trunks is a time traveler the
first we see in this series a moment
that shifts the reality of this world
yet again he also admits to making a
very foolish mistake a mistake that
places an emphasis on trunks's naivety
and one that demonstrates Goku's
competence as a warrior and
steadfastness as someone we can rely on
once again highlighting for us that
everything will be okay because Goku is
here to protect us this is all to say
that from the very moment this Arc
begins Akira Toriyama is deliberately
placing the notion in all of our heads
that without Goku the future is lost
which while consistent with the prior
arcs of this story something about this
Arc does feel distinctly different to
either the Frieza or the Saiyan sagas
while those prior stories offered a
variety of different points of view or B
plots to follow along with for the First
Act and some of the second act of this
story there's a specific emphasis placed
on Goku that doesn't really let up taken
away from the likes of Vegeta and Gohan
who both enjoyed their own beat plots in
the last arc our attention once again is
firmly on Son Goku for what feels like
the first time since the 23rd Tenkaichi
Budokai a conscious decision that was
made to only further emphasize what will
be the single greatest series of payoffs
this story has ever delivered and quite
possibly ever will and so while trunks's
arrival has been spectacular and the
revelation of time travel once again
opens up a ton of possibilities and
while Goku is presented as the one true
hope for mankind this is only one aspect
one element of what makes this a truly
interesting and emotionally engaging
story you see unlike what this story is
telling us about Goku being the most
important character to follow there's
another dimension to the story one that
follows another character that so
desperately wants to be the one to lead
the way and another who so desperately
doesn't and it's the path that each of
these two Venture down and how Goku's
character influences their respective
decisions that ultimately makes this one
of the best arcs out there in its unique
approach and so trunks leaves Chichi
agrees to allow Gohan train with his
father in Piccolo all the while everyone
else endures their own intense
independent training with the change
from the previous two axes pattern of
wait for Goku to having the entire
future seemingly resting on his
shoulders now as I said the aura
surrounding Goku almost feels like that
which he possessed during the 23rd
Tenkaichi Budokai a returning hero from
a mystical land possessing otherworldly
strength and a destiny to fulfill as the
Earth's number one Defender showing off
his teleportation revealing his
dominance on over trunks it seems
despite the efforts of other fighters in
this series at this present time having
Goku on her team almost feels like
cheating
until it doesn't
the stretch of story that follows this
three-year time skip leading up to the
eventual reveal of cell is perhaps one
of the most fascinating case studies of
Akira toriyama's writing style that I've
come across so far I spoke of the Marist
that his loose make it up as he goes
along type approach offered him with the
likes of Raditz and while that imprecise
flexibility offered him room to
carefully maneuver his narrative here it
too created some unusual and difficult
problems that he needed to solve on the
Fly no less with hindsight and behind
the scenes knowledge it's of course
easier for us to detect the course
corrections but after having reread this
material for the purposes of this review
with all of that in mind I have to say I
was blown away by toriyama's ability to
Pivot certain aspects of the story in
ways that both reinforce the ongoing
narrative and feel natural and what's
more is I think I noticed a few things
that could have been indicators of where
the story may have been going had he
been left alone to pursue his initial
Vision a vision that is as of yet
totally uninterrupted and speaking of
there's something rather spooky and
innately interesting about the Android's
impending Invasion here we have so
little information about them other than
the Bleak picture that trunks described
of his future a massive component of the
early Frieza material concerned the
earthlings using their ability to sense
key to gain the advantage over their
enemies but for this Arc that concept is
sort of flipped onto its head as the
Androids are not capable of being sensed
at all creating a very unique scene
where both the audience reading along
and the heroes of Earth after yajirobe's
exit experience a genuinely shocking
occurrence
[Applause]
this was one of the few times this story
genuinely created a sense of unease
within me the likes of Goku Gohan
Piccolo these guys don't get surprised
in this way often or at all really and
after waiting all of this time to see
these Androids hoping to get the drop on
them to gain the advantage that trunks
was hoping for to avoid that future it
seems they've already turned the tables
on our heroes seeing those Anonymous
dots of the Androids descend onto the
unassuming tongue below it's truly
unsettling and it only gets uglier from
this point forward
introductions are important to Akira
Toriyama he uses them as a vehicle to
communicate the central elements of the
characters as they debut for Napa he
acted with tremendous cruelty and power
but he too was Reckless pointed out by
Vegeta alongside numerous other
instances where he clearly demonstrated
an elite level of observation and
strategic prowess for Frieza the tone
was entirely different Frieza enjoyed
playing with his victims watching them
squirm as if he were a cat and they were
his food there's a sadistic nature to
his introduction that drives home just
how twisted and cruel Frieza is however
with the Androids it almost feels empty
terrifyingly so they dispatch people not
to prove a point not to announce their
presence or to even play with the fear
they see in others they are simply
moving through people striking them down
in the same way a person walking down
the street dispassionately steps on some
ants there's a doubling almost
horror-like Aura to this introduction
and one that is emphasized when Yamcha
steps in to stop the madness
foreign
how this is depicted in both the anime
and the manga it is so dramatic so
horrifying so sudden and while this all
leads to the gang converging on this
location lickety-split my favorite part
of this section has to be the subtle
foreshadowing hinting towards Goku's
physical state
his heart virus evidence of these
surfaces in the story long before his
eventual Tango with Android 19 however
and even before he turns Super Saiyan
the very first time I noticed this
illness impacting Goku came about even
before he arrived on the scene to make
the save on Yamcha Android 2019 had been
looking for Goku to get their revenge on
behalf of the Red Ribbon Army but Goku
isn't feeling as amazing as he otherwise
looked during his demonstration against
trunks little droplets of sweat begin to
appear after virtually no effort or
exertion on the Saiyan a status that
only Cascades from bad to terrible as he
stands across the battlefield from the
terrifyingly cartoonish Android 19.
igniting his explosive transformation
from Saiyan Legend right out the gate as
both he and 19 are engulfed in his
Golden Glow and again much the same way
my attention was drawn to Goku during
the Android's introduction despite the
explosive battle that's a about to take
place between Goku and 19 my attention
this time found Anchorage amidst the
inside Piccolo offers this worsening
situation and the point of view Akira
Toriyama purposefully depicts all of
this from
[Music]
ah
and so here we finally are the battle
between Goku and the Androids commences
one that trunks set up as the
destination for this story and what's
more is by virtue of Goku making it to
this battlefield we've already
successfully Changed History
or so we think and get used to saying
that because one thing this act does
exceptionally well early on is keep us
as an audience off balance and asking
questions and here is honestly no
different for as soon as Goku erupts
into battle stunning the likes of
tenshinhan and even the Androids
themselves with his immense Super Saiyan
power as we bask in that moment Piccolo
quickly brings to our attention
something very Talent pensively watching
on he makes note that Goku quite
uncharacteristically started this fight
at 100
Goku never does this he always leaves
something in reserve because to Goku
this is supposed to be fun he never
wants to rush to the end if he can help
it which means Goku despite only having
just started and clearly dominating this
fight isn't having fun up there and
what's more is as time takes on by it
starts to appear as though Goku is
fighting for every single breath at this
point in the story the cause of Goku's
fatigue is actually rather ambiguous and
mysterious though we may take that for
granted nowadays as many of us have the
benefit of hindsight there is obviously
the looming thought of the proposed
heart virus at play but we know Goku has
already been given the medicine for that
and what's more is we have the currently
unknown element of the Android supposed
power draining abilities Yamcha believes
it may be through their hands but we
really have no idea at this point so as
Goku continues to get worse and worse
with Piccolo and Co speculating on it
all we are left as readers to speculate
ourselves about what in the world is
happening to Goku this fight and how
it's presented to us by the way is pure
Cinema in the most subtle of ways
because the way this fight is framed
from the get-go forces me as a reader to
feel fundamentally off balance compared
to every single other Goku fight in the
series as alluded to earlier this story
tells us time and again how so important
Goku is how he's Central to the story
for instance trunks comes back in time
specifically to save who Goku Android 20
otherwise known as Dr Duro states that
they are specifically after who Goku
again he's the focus like he has been in
previous story arcs only within this
fight unlike every other which enjoyed
some verbal jousting strategy and a more
personal point of view within the fight
themselves we see none of this from the
perspective of Goku himself in fact
we're taken completely out of it which
as a reader creates this bizarre sense
of unease as the fight trudges towards
an inevitable outcome instead of
enjoying the fight from the point of
view of Goku like we normally would this
fight has our attention squarely on the
reactions of his allies and enemies as
they slowly notice that something is
happening to Goku and react in terrified
or in the case of Piccolo strategic ways
as a whole this fight is a wonderfully
executed swerve that leads ultimately
into a fight that showcases an
exceptionally powerful Swerve City
[Music]
foreign
Vegeta vs Android 19. this is for many
Vegeta fans one of the most cathartic
and fulfilling fights he gets to enjoy
for the majority of the series and that
out of the loop feeling we felt in the
other fight with Goku is now entirely
replaced with a very familiar and
comfortable Beatdown that we get to
experience first hand alongside the
returning and triumphant Saiyan Prince
Vegeta as he lays verbal barbs and
thunderously heavy attacks with a smile
against this cheap toy despite the
praise Super Vegeta eventually receives
and despite the epic battle between a
Super Saiyan Vegeta and Android 19 here
Vegeta as a character is I think
critically underappreciated as one of
the central stories told in this Arc not
because he doesn't have his fans he
definitely does tons of them but more so
because I think a lot of people don't
fully appreciate the depth of the story
that Vegeta enjoys in this Arc a story
that if we were to go without it the
fight itself that perhaps off this Arc
would have finished a very very
different way while Goku was firmly in
the spotlight Vegeta had largely
disappeared in this lead up to the
Android thread and now in true Vegeta
fashion he makes his presence
thunderously felt not only derailing
piccolos frankly absurdly brilliant fake
out to get the drop on the Androids but
also making the save on her central
point of Interest Goku appearing as a
Super Saiyan for the very first time in
his own right Vegeta claims to have
pushed himself to the point of
self-hatred when suddenly it happened
the Golden Glow of the Super Saiyan
erupted from deep within the prince once
again reclaiming his throne and so in
the interest of keeping Vegeta's story
at the Forefront of our minds when we
look at this exceptionally cathartic and
fun fight between him and Android 19. we
should also keep the broader context of
the story in mind for instance and
generally at the beginning of story arcs
there is typically a mission statement
or broad set of themes established that
the entire Arc adheres to or Works
towards in the case of the Saiyan Saga
it was rather explicit Raditz
represented the ideology Goku would need
to prove himself against using what he
learned instead of what he was told he
was however in this Arc there's a very
interesting interaction between Goku and
Vegeta that takes place once they
reunite following Frieza and trunks's
battle one that says a lot about the
journey Vegeta's character goes on in
this Arc and the role Goku will play in
that it's honestly fantastic Vegeta says
don't think you don't need us just
because you became a Super Saiyan I will
beat you sooner or later I will prove
again that I'm the strongest of the
Saiyans and to that Goku simply responds
whatever God I love that it's subtle but
I love it because I don't think you
could find a more succinct and complete
example of what Goku and Vegeta stand
for in this series and hilariously
Vegeta still doesn't see that Goku has
zero intro interest in being the
strongest the fact Vegeta's managed to
sense key or train in the same way Goku
did may show a respect for things that
have worked for others in the past but
it's other people he wants to be better
than and this interaction highlights a
fundamental flaw in Vegeta's approach I
think his inability to cooperate with
others to work as part of a team towards
a greater goal always choosing to train
alone and so while we look on and
rightfully enjoy this incredible
Beatdown between 19 and Vegeta Toriyama
is intentionally giving Vegeta
everything he wants here he's the
strongest once again and he achieved
this through his own tried and true
methodology his grit his hatred and his
ruthless determination to achieve his
goals has led him to the Promised Land
once again and oh it feels good
foreign
Vegeta's Bluff right here is perhaps one
of my favorite panels from the manga
there's so much subtle depth to this
character and the strategy I play here
that it just melts my brain in more ways
than one this is Vegeta at the peak of
his powers he's loving every single
second and much the same way he was able
to navigate Dynamic material here too
he's able to leverage his cunning and
psychological experience in combat to
gain an advantage whenever and wherever
he can and this moment was exactly that
a bluff a moment where Vegeta defeats
Android 20 in psychological warfare
Vegeta is a genius but he's not perfect
foreign
for those that are familiar with the
behind the scenes workflow of Akira
Toriyama and his editors this Arc in
particular has a certain reputation a
reputation for being somewhat disjointed
or at the very least meddled with early
on forcing Toriyama to constantly pivot
the story's focus at the whim of his
current editor condo you and while his
editor is undeniably and factually the
reason we get the likes of Android 17
and 18 later as well as sell himself
eventually I think the major thing that
goes underappreciated here is just how
beautifully and almost seamlessly
Toriyama weaves these narrative pivots
together what could easily have been an
arc that felt fragmented and unfocused
is instead arguably Toriyama at his most
Unstoppable by the time this Arc rolls
around toriyama's writing style has gone
from scatting along with the story doing
his best to keep up with his own ideas
to completely mastering the free-form
Jazz approach here it's like watching
Miles Davis up on stage taking every
possible New Direction with infinite new
ones and Poise both with the upcoming
editor-driven swerves as well as his own
personal ideas for this Arc nothing goes
unaccounted for in advance though it may
be subtle this Arc is filled to the brim
with discreet setups and payoffs small
key moments that establish some unstable
elements and then pay off or resolve
them much later down the line one of the
earliest instances that caught my eye in
particular was this straight line from
Vegeta regarding his Super Saiyan
transformation in it he says I forgot to
mention when I become a Super Saiyan my
ferocity increases too we enter a
certain ecstatic State you see between
this line and how they are portrayed
even as early as Goku vs Frieza there's
a very specific Quirk to Super Saiyan
that Toriyama seemingly always had in
mind for this transformation the fact
that Super Saiyan not only makes you a
bit more ruthless in personality but
subsequently that ferocity leads to a
very different pace of fight though the
anime would drag the these out every
single fight featuring a Super Saiyan in
this Arc is remarkably short they are
not belabored affairs with the usual
progression we were accustomed to but
rather extremely quick and volatile
exchanges this element is brought back
into Focus later on with the likes of
Goku and Vegeta seeking out an evolution
to the form all the way to the sun
family strategy of mastering Super
Saiyan for the Cell Games these sorts of
long Play Elements and foreshadowing are
something that were usually fairly
sparse and Toriyama stories but this Arc
is just absolutely jam-packed with them
it's incredible how cohesive and thought
out it all feels despite our knowledge
of the editor's Perpetual influence with
that said however as Android 20 tried
and failed to make his getaway from the
forces of Earth because I had these
specific story pivots fresh in my mind
to watch out for while I ride along I
became fixated on trying to figure out
what Direction the Story might have gone
in had Toriyama been left to his devices
with the story he had planned and
honestly I think I stumbled across
something that might be a relic of a
plot thread that ultimately never went
anywhere because of all the constant
changes to it after Gohan makes the save
on Piccolo who later goes on to totally
wreck Android 20 by the way seriously
that knee to the face was cold as
Gohan was sent away from the action and
that's when something occurred to me
while Android 20 feels markedly weaker
and much less of a big deal than he
otherwise did upon his introduction at
this point I noticed that despite the
absence of Gohan and Goku in the main
party at no point while I was reading
did I feel like the main story lacked
any star power Vegeta Piccolo tenshinhan
trunks Krillin all of these characters
apart from trunks were once antagonist
in the story and that's a cute
observation sure but it brought to my
attention something pivotal to this
story The Future that trunks himself
came from
oh my God chowser's dead
and he really let himself go
and he's an Android if you think back to
what trunks divulged about his future it
was one ravaged by two Androids the
likes of which never got to fight Goku
the likes of whom killed Vegeta Piccolo
ten shinhan and Krillin an encounter
that only a select few survived and who
were those select few well who did
Piccolo send home just now before going
to gero's lab Bulma baby trunks yajirobi
and to transport them all
Son Gohan
according to trunks Bulma himself and
Gohan were the ones who survived and if
we look at Super's continuation both in
the anime and the manga who else
survived yajirobi though does that count
really I don't know I'll let you decide
that but personally with the way this
story was shaping up concerning the new
Androids that were to be awakened with
Goku on his deathbed the forces of Earth
about to face trunks's future and the
cast Gohan is carrying it's fun to
consider the parallels between that very
Future Trunks warned us of alongside
this present day one and the potential
story Akira Toriyama was toying with
before he was asked again to shift his
focus elsewhere I honestly think in a
world where Toriyama saw his original
plan for 19 and 22 fruition he may have
legitimately planned on having the arc
begin with the very same tragedy trunks
endured in his timeline only for them to
somehow recover from it it's up for you
guys to speculate how you think that
might have unfolded but for now it's
just a fun thought experiment
foreign
I won't pontificate over the likes of 17
and 18 for too long as once again we
will pivot to sell but before that
eventually happens I do want to draw
attention to an interesting aspect of
their characterization and a plot thread
that was potentially again left
abandoned as trunks has pointed out the
timeline's events have changed
considerably to his own not only were
the Androids that appeared near South
City very different to what he predicted
and not only were Goku's heart virus
issues delayed but the personalities of
17 and 18 seem to have been altered too
at no point of 17 18 or even 16 declare
that they quote wanted to kill Goku but
instead that they were designed to kill
him or that they were looking to defeat
him apart from the very obvious
undertones of freedom and Free Will
being a key theme that follows these two
tragic characters something 17 said in
passing when he noted the differences
between himself and Android 16 they
caught my eye he wondered why Dr gero
went back to kidnapping children for
human-based Android experimentation
following the success that was Android
16. an entirely mechanical fighter it's
a very interesting question for him to
ask and one that isn't explored or
answered at all in this story
unfortunately
foreign
[Music]
versus Android 18 following his dominant
display against the likes of Android 19
Vegeta finds himself once again with his
authority and presence challenged but I
think most importantly what hurts Vegeta
is that despite having left the story
almost entirely Android 16 17 and 18
site Goku as their primary target a
factual Revelation that exposes Vegeta's
greatest weakness and establishes the
journey his character will ultimately
undergo In This Very Arc and that
journey is one of self-acceptance and
humility to on some level confront his
own insecurities and in the Prelude as
well as within some elements of this
very fight it echoes many of the
characteristics the prior contest
between himself and Android 19 boasted
so explicitly Vegeta is loving life
talking trash and sitting in his mind
comfortably atop the totem pole as the
strongest warrior in the universe
there's no chance he could be bested by
anyone not by his son not by these
Androids and certainly not by Kakarot
and this aspect of his character is on
some level admirable for a lot of people
I'm sure this Vegeta we get in this Arc
acts as a symbol for hard work in the
series throwing himself into impossibly
rough situations to push himself to his
physical limits sacrificing years of his
life in the name of becoming the
absolute strongest however there's a
fundamental flaw with his approach and
more than that for me
he's never really represented what true
hard work means or at least not as much
as many might suggest he does in this
Arc anyway and that's because in this
material despite destroying himself
physically he always seems to choose to
stay well within his comfort zone you
gotta remember isolating himself from
others training rigorously resolutely
pushing himself in the same way he
always has it's strenuous training yes
but this is an approach well within his
comfort zone he so desperately wants to
be the leader so desperately wants to be
the strongest the alpha of the group
that he always stands above all but the
truth is that not everyone can be the
leader not everyone can be the strongest
and not everyone wants to be either for
the likes of Goku who always seems to
have his eyes fixated on the horizon
preparing for the possibility of someone
else coming around the next Corner
that's even better even stronger for
Vegeta this very idea this notion that
he's the strongest in the universe is
the in his armor that leaves him
open to attack
amazing denying help denying the reality
that stands right before him Vegeta
would rather die than accept help from
someone else to challenge himself
emotionally to accept that he is wrong
and quite fittingly it's trunks Vegeta's
son that offers an interesting angle to
view his character from and that angle
is a point of view of the Saiyan Prince
we've not yet seen in the past we've
heard Vegeta described as Sinister evil
chaotic ruthless or driven at best but
lonely is a descriptor I've only heard
trunks Echo and it's such a fascinating
interpretation of this character we've
not yet explored while not demonstrated
to us directly we can tell that trunks
had prior to his arrival on this
timeline certain expectations of his
father expectations that the actual
Vegeta failed to live up to in the most
basic of ways expectations that while we
haven't seen their roots clearly stem
from his mother Bulma who earlier in
this very story Vegeta chose not to save
when Android 20 attacked her plane in an
effort to distract them because again
sentiment isn't something that ever
concerns the likes of Vegeta how lonely
that must be but trunks doesn't operate
that way trunks wanted to save his
mother and he did and true to his
character despite his disillusionment in
his own father
he wants to save him too but as has been
the story for trunks's entire life
he just can't save him
[Music]
truly and in every sense of the word
trunks is the
Catalyst to expose all of Vegeta's
issues here he warns them all against
fighting the Androids and allowing them
to be activated he warns them all about
the importance of waiting for Son Goku
to help the
if it doesn't take heed however refusing
to take the lead from anyone he said it
himself quote I need no one but it's so
clear that he does in more ways than one
he needs people he just can't admit it
this is where things go from bad to
worse to curiously odd Vegeta crumbles
following his final arm breaking
compelling trunks to try and fail to
make the save here but it's not just
these two who fall
everyone does with Krillin Frozen from
Fear as a notable exception clearly the
least equipped to deal with what's
transpired with Piccolo and the two
Super Saiyans having fallen easily
before his eyes he's unable to bring
himself to even move out of line an inch
and again while reading this I was taken
aback by how reasonable it would have
been for readers to assume that history
was heading in the same direction as it
had for trunks's timeline all the pieces
are in place the medicine might be
ineffective leading Goku and yamsha to
die everyone on the battlefield could
perish to the Androids and all who'd
remain would be Gohan and his passengers
on route to his house but that doesn't
happen instead 17 18 and 16 all
consciously decide to leave everyone
live and more than that in fact there's
an argument to be made that if Vegeta
wasn't leaving the charge here a fight
might not even have taken place
foreign
Piccolo and Kami feels
special it's the first time they've
spoken since the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai
which didn't go all too great by the way
and to tell you the truth I love the
subtle undertones of toriyama's
character writing here it's clear why
Piccolo is there and what's more is it's
clear that Piccolo isn't the same as his
father something Kami even himself
acknowledges right away and with that
acknowledgment there is a palpable
sadness in kami's demeanor a lot of
people rightfully appreciate this scene
as one of the most significant moments
in Piccolo's life a moment that marks
the final chapter of Piccolo's character
Arc closing the book on a story which
saw these two separate and fight for an
entire age and while that is fantastic
and worthy of Praise in and of itself
what I loved about this scene can be
observed through a specific line of
dialogue that was shared after being
confronted by the Grim reality that they
are facing Kami is forced to acknowledge
his own limitations how he the guard of
Earth its protector can no longer stand
watch over it or protect it for not even
the comparatively bottomless power of
Trunks Vegeta or even Son Goku can stand
up to this new threat to which Piccolo
reaffirms quite simply that's right what
the earth needs now isn't a god it needs
me with power enough to defeat them Kami
does go on to wait a little while longer
passively holding out in hope that the
actions of the Androids have come about
due to provocation and not their own
desires for conflict
but despite this holdout for another
alternative for a passive solution a
hold out for something or someone to
stop this from taking place
Kami agrees to surrender himself to
Piccolo
to become one for me it's honestly
impossible not to see the parallels here
between this moment and the climax of
this Arc a Bittersweet moment of
reconciliation and submission and
acquiescing of one's ideals a
relinquishing of control or in the name
of the greater good and truthfully this
is about as close as Toriyama gets to
showing the cracks of what he's dealing
with behind the scenes Piccolo arrives
and waits on the lookout for God knows
how long tension on goes to check on
shoutsu Krillin shifts the location of
Goku and Company away from his home it's
clear with the benefit of hindsight that
Toriyama was trying to figure out what
his next move should be or at the very
least was trying to put the various
pieces of this puzzle in place for the
next phase this would normally bother me
but truthfully looking at this material
today he handles it amazingly well
foreign
throughout this Arc so far the entire
narrative has been consistently evolving
with a feeling of instability and unease
Frieza arrives but trunks negates it
Androids arrive but are flukes that lead
to 17 and 18 but even then there's a
sort of directional mystery with these
Androids as they don't seem particularly
married to the idea of evil destruction
or even necessarily killing Goku or
anyone for that matter all of that
instability and mystery comes folding in
on itself however with this one reveal
it's magnificently done shoving yet
another mystery into the mix the second
time machine feels purposefully out of
left field and unnerving pretty much
every Twist and Turn we've been on so
far has felt like a natural progression
of events but this time machine it
doesn't fit at all like a chess piece
suddenly appearing on a checkers board
and it doesn't take long before it is
very parent that this is in fact the
single most important piece in the
entire story so far between the reveal
of the giant cicada looking shell on the
ground trunks's utter befuddlement at
the impossibility of it all and most
importantly Kami immediately agreeing to
fuse with Piccolo when this development
comes to his attention everything is
instantly brought into Focus it's hard
to overstate how unnerving and
disruptive this revealed feels the power
of the Androids already seemed
insurmountable absolutely trouncing the
current's strongest character with only
one combatant but they were a known
entity in fact now that I think of it
there aren't really any major villains
in Dragon Ball that are revealed as such
an unknown as cell Vegeta was warned
about by Raditz the heroes were warned
of Frieza long before his debut and even
Demon King Piccolo was known by roshi as
he returned but there is absolutely
nothing we know about this new creature
at this very moment what does a giant
shell have to do with a time machine why
has it been here for nearly a year
before trunks originally arrived to stop
Frieza why is its mere presence even as
a larva so unnerving that has thrown
Kami off for years how is there even a
second identical time machine to begin
with though all of these questions will
be answered in due time it is the
introduction of those questions that
sells this mystery and acts as the
Catalyst for the second act of this
story as Kami and Piccolo reunite after
centuries of separation and rushed to
the site of distress mere miles from
where the time machine was found
[Music]
this reveal is unlike anything we've
ever seen in Dragon Ball almost like a
rat or snake that has been hiding under
our Collective noses a series of creepy
news broadcasts in the manga revealed
the Curious events surrounding a place
called gingertown and while it's
immensely effective I think the
Cinematic approach Toriyama was trying
to go for was limited by the medium he
was telling his story through I'm an
avid lover of manga as many of you know
and stand by it as my preferred medium
to digest stories in but even I cannot
deny the Cinematic Masterpiece that is
cell's anime introduction slow moving
Shadows found footage straight articles
of clothing strewn suspiciously all
around and random items tossed across
our screens by the Eerie Breeze of the
wind all the while we hear footsteps
echo in the deafening silence
it's terrifyingly effective bringing to
life a Sinister atmosphere the likes of
which we've never seen in this story
before and this my friends is Akira
toriyama's introduction of cell
foreign
[Music]
Piccolo versus Cell
this fight between Piccolo and cell is
one steeped in mystery with an intense
atmosphere and quite wonderfully as soon
as cell opens his mouth as audience
members our list of questions only seems
to grow how does he talk I thought he
was an animal how does he know who
Piccolo is and his history why does his
energy feel like everyone all of this
coupled with the intensely graphic
methodology he uses to absorb a helpless
citizen creates this enormous question
mark over cell and his Origins
or does it as it happens we have already
received a subtle indication of where
this creature has come from if we cast
our minds back we know that Dr gero has
been Gathering data on all of the
greatest warriors to ever fight on Earth
Energy that seems to be infused with and
matches the energy emitted by this cell
it's subtle but it's a beautiful
foreshadowed introduction of where he
comes from and just goes to further show
how brilliantly Toriyama manages to take
seeds from previous chapters and utilize
them to their fullest regardless of what
direction the story is taking and
honestly despite this fight having some
of the best full-page spreads in the
manga it's not the action that makes up
the focus of this battle but instead
the exposition
is
[Music]
this is an inspired narrative Choice
made by Akira Toriyama I think at this
print time due to the constant changes
to his initial plan Toriyama is in a
position where he needs cell to divulge
his plan and Exposition to us so that we
can finally leave this establishment
section of the story and to achieve this
Toriyama leverages two narrative
elements at his disposal cell's surprise
factor and Piccolo's strategic
Brilliance Piccolo once again faking an
injury to get the drop in his opponent
this time it actually gets the chance to
work and to great effect sell much like
Vegeta and Frieza wood decides to gloat
and spill the beans on his background
granting both Piccolo and Us by proxy at
home the necessary insight and
Exposition through internally consistent
strategy all the while creating a
purpose for the Rogue Androids to
fulfill narratively a narrative purpose
that ironically robs them of their own
purpose it should also be noted that as
a backup story for these Androids to
explore a path that forces them to once
again be part of someone else's plan is
compelling and rather perfect turning
them forcing them once more to be
nothing more than another's puppet
lacking autonomy and a basic level of
freedom in other words cell wants
nothing more than to strip the meaning
from their lives away for the sake of
his own selfish quest for Perfection and
power remind you of anyone in the end
this fight exists purely for exposition
and to alert the likes of cell to the
powers the earthlings possess in a way
it's a confrontation that approaches a
similar problem Toriyama was faced with
during the namic material where Krillin
and Gohan were almost discovered by
Vegeta only in this scene I think
everything is logically consistent and
held together with reasonable precaution
and cunning strategy and not luck so
yeah I love this scene and from this
point on the plot that was once shrouded
in mystery and curiosity focuses itself
tremendously narrowing in on the main
through line forcing the themes and the
ideas that were once offered up as
breadcrumbs thus far to take shape and
establish for us a clear path forward a
path that has taken the obvious shape of
stop sell from absorbing the Androids at
all costs however for me there's always
been so much more to this story than
simply this surface level observation
foreign
as he looks out of his window trying to
make sense of a world that has changed
so much since he was last conscious
Goku's first words are heartwarming they
are directed to Chichi he says Chichi
sorry I worried you I'm all better now
despite the chaos that has raged since
he fell to Android 19 Goku still finds
time to consider the feelings of those
he loves and in that moment we're
reminded of what Goku is he's our anchor
someone we can rely on that no matter
what's taking place Goku will unlike
others be able to keep his head and more
than that formulate a plan of action
foreign
this is one of the most seismic moments
in the entire series and I'm willing to
wager not for the reasons many of you
are considering right now at this very
moment and I say that because despite it
being such a pivotal and considerable
shift in the narrative direction of the
story it's also one of the most subtle a
little after this the Androids arrive
looking for Goku and seizing this moment
Piccolo challenges 17 to a fight and
following that they disperse leaving
Krillin and tension hunt behind it
Roshi's Krillin then goes to retrieve
the new remote developed by Bulma and 10
shinhan rushes to the battlefield where
Piccolo is there's a ton of moving Parts
here but my attention fell squarely on
this one small panel where roshi shared
with us something he has clearly been
thinking about for a long time having
watched Goku pick himself up and
formulate a plan of action having seen
krillin's courage and ten shinhan's
desire to contribute in any way he can
roshi in a quiet moment of
self-reflection utters to himself hard
to imagine days where I was the
strongest in the world
and within the context of the story I
think this one line from roshi speaks to
the mindset Akira Toriyama was in at
this time for those that haven't read or
watched the early Dragon Ball material
this will likely mean nothing to you but
for me it forced me to recall the
beginning of this story the 21st
Tenkaichi Budokai is the second Arc of
this long long story and to this day
remains one of the most unique in its
Narrative Approach because despite the
story centering itself around a
tournament to Crown the quote strongest
under the heavens the tale itself is not
about winning but instead the lessons
one stands to learn from losing and the
efforts and lengths the ones with great
power must go to to ensure those lessons
are passed down to those with the most
potential there are several instances in
early Dragon Ball where roshi has the
likes of Goku Krillin and even
tenshinhan pegged as his successors the
Next Generation to defend the Earth from
catastrophe and look at all of these
pupils coming together to protect
against something he couldn't possibly
protect against I can't imagine how
Vindicated he must feel in that moment
in that panel and I draw attention to
this because I think it serves as a
subtle indicator on the role Goku will
soon play in this story
a role he will soon find himself Within
ever since Goku's return to Earth after
Frieza something has felt off and with
his fault the likes of Android 19 now
waking up to a brand new set of
circumstances in the home that helped
shape him as a martial artist Goku's
priorities have realigned and through
subtle character or care as Goku
suggests the room of spirit and time
Toriyama is laying the groundwork for a
transition of power a transition of
focus a transition of responsibility for
this is the very moment Goku was no
longer the main character of Dragon Ball
and there's evidence for this all over
the text
foreign
however while this training goes unseen
another fight starts to get underway hey
can Goku come out and die the science
has no solicitors
[Music]
Goku and Gohan are forced to sit on the
sidelines as another brutal encounter
rages on below but for now the strongest
in the universe isn't Goku Gohan trunks
or even Vegeta it's the namekian warrior
staring down a couple of brazen Androids
a super namekian who right now has a
chance to turn the tides on the Elusive
and evasive cell in other words he is a
chance to save the world as fights in
this series go despite my enjoyment of
it outside of a few cool moments it
primarily serves one purpose to act as a
homing Beacon to help bring cell and the
Androids together for the longest time
while everyone else was scrambling
Piccolo was trying desperately to catch
up to cell before he absorbed more
people having reunited with Kami for the
sole purpose of saving the Earth from
cell with each passing day he was unable
to dispose of this creature more people
would fall victim to his attacks and
with no Dragon Balls to wish them back
to life now that Kami has been
assimilated into Piccolo the stakes have
never been higher in the broader context
of this series this is Piccolo swan song
a lost namekian that once upon a time
purged himself of the darkness Humanity
infected him with now finds himself
standing as the sole protector of Earth
a planet he once tried to rule over to
enslave and Destroy This one-time
villain of villains has decided to
reconcile his differences with his other
half reuniting any final Gambit to save
the planet he was once so feverishly
desperate to dominate it's an easy thing
to forget during this battle with all of
its flashy moves and sudden shock
appearances but I think this is
genuinely a wonderful moment for Piccolo
2. 17's characterization in this Arc is
great also he's very much in every sense
of the word a teen rebelling against the
system that designed him that robbed him
of everything made obvious by his
consistent refusal to believe anyone is
more powerful than he however despite
this there's always a certain
consideration in the background of his
actions like choosing to spare everyone
after their first initial encounter when
he really didn't need to no one was
going to or could stop him if he so
chose
but he didn't and even within this fight
he asks to move the action to a more
remote location in order to protect the
environment these are things villains do
not say and one cell makes his presence
felt that unsure youth dwelling within
17 made itself known immediately
shifting to Piccolo's side for security
16 is a curious case there's clearly an
entire story concerning him that largely
went unexplored that I will get into
later however while I was watching this
all unfold for the first time back in
the day I really couldn't get a read on
this character however now I think
through his actions and inaction a much
clearer picture is drawn outright
refusing to do harm to anyone prior
showing no interest in anything other
than the lightheaded actions of 17 18
and some wildlife and the first time he
actually steps in to fight anyone is
against cell and why to protect his
friends frenzy had been watching and
understood as good people quote I liked
YouTube
you never killed without reason the
action with Android 16 in this section
is tremendous everything from the rocket
punch which is a fan favorite
all the way to the detachable arms that
reveal cannons a design approach taken
perhaps to juxtapose his quiet and
demure demeanor with destructive
capabilities a convincingly human
exterior with monstrous power dwelling
within however it is that emotion in 17
that he values that innate Humanity he
possesses the Teen Angst and desire to
Rebel that ultimately leads to 17's
downfall because no matter how powerful
he thinks he is or how free he wants to
be
this story isn't his and in a world with
cell personal autonomy and Free Will are
about fleeting luxuries and Illusions
what a perfect oppressive and dominating
line for cell to other to 17. right
before he strips the young Android of
everything he holds dear no less Piccolo
has failed Android 16 has failed the
force of nature that itself very much
feels like an inevitability here an
entity that has LeapFrog over everyone
around him in strength multiple times
over before even his first
transformation
let's see
this is a pivotal point in the story a
moment in time that our body raises
Piccolo from The Narrative ensures the
Androids can do nothing except run and
for the likes of Goku and Gohan all they
can do is sit and watch and yeah that's
right even for the likes of Goku a
character that seemed to always have an
answer for everything he knows it's
useless it's a dynamic we never see from
him he was always down to dive head
first into even the most impossible odds
ready to face Frieza even when he wasn't
much stronger than Ginyu but here he is
so outgunned that he knows even he
shouldn't try however there is still one
ruffle to the story that cell didn't
account for and a tribute of the Earth's
forces that was once on display for all
to see during the Saiyan Invasion and
that attribute is
the indomitable strength and tenacity of
earthlings to push past their limits and
risk their lives to struggle against a
tremendous evil
shaking
I adore this scene and I love it because
it reinforces this idea that true
strength can be hiding in the most
unlikely of places the tri-beam kikoho
or whatever your dog referred to this
move as is another technique from early
Dragon Ball that boasts a tremendous
amount of recoil on the wielder with
every subsequent shot fired at cell it
drags tension on closer and closer to
death's door we've seen it used during
the 22nd Tenkaichi Budokai and the
Saiyan Invasion but there's a reason
this scene in particular has such Die
Hard fans in a world where every human
fighter has been totally outclassed to
the point of utter uselessness present
at the original fight against Android's
19 and 20 only as an act of
spectatorship it's easy to feel that the
stakes have been raised such that only
Saiyans or super namekians need apply
but tenshinan shows up here for one last
ultimate push a final self-sacrificing
explosion of power giving his literal 1
hundred and ten percent in order to keep
sell busy for just a few seconds it very
much feels like the last hurray for
humankind and feels all the more
inspirational as a result and while
inspirational and enormously impressive
this is still just a proverbial lasso
tension Hunt is forcing a round cell
something utilized to buy time for 18
and 16 to gather themselves up and hide
from this monster and forced to look on
as Piccolo's key drops to zero and
tension on two heads in that very same
direction Goku reaches his Wit's End and
is forced to take action
wait no no
how impossible do the odds feel at this
present moment in time cell has
demonstrated that he's a monstrously and
unfathomably powerful and as of right
now it's only a matter of time before he
can find Android 18. a person's cell
will capture only because she was too
selfless and couldn't abandon 16 in his
current state I did however make an
observation during this material about
the Instant Transmission introduced
during the opening scene of this Arc the
Instant Transmission is specifically
designed to lock onto a key signature
thus allowing the wielder to access
tremendous movement in exchange for a
momentary refocusing of attention and it
looks as though this was a technique
designed specifically for this Arc if we
recall the original moment Android's 19
and 20 made themselves known to the
group they were specifically
undetectable through key sensitivity as
were 16 17 and 18. and so I genuinely
think it would have been interesting to
see how Toriyama would have written a
story leveraging that technique against
a threat with such obvious advantages
over it at any rate I think toriyama's
eventual use of it here is near perfect
given the circumstances Goku Zooms in to
save Piccolo and ten chinhan but
naturally cannot take 18 out of the
battle because
can't locate her but of course no
development in this Arc goes without its
answers without the seeds that were
planted long ago sprouting and in this
case it's been just about long enough
for that room of spirit and time
business to yield some results
[Music]
strained relationship between Vegeta and
Trunks is one of two plot threads I'd
like to explore in this section
primarily because for me this is the
best Akira toriyama's writing has ever
been the story of a Saiyan warrior who
rejects sentimentality in the name of
Pride and power and a young naive son
that so desperately wants to find the
humanity and bond he never got the
chance to have with his own father is
one ripe for exploration and dramatic
tension and because their time in the
chamber together took place entirely off
screen it allowed Toriyama to leverage
all of that uncertainty we have
surrounding their relationship to great
effect from the very moment Goku
mentions the room of spirit and time to
Vegeta he understands the issues that
exist between him and Trunks how Vegeta
doesn't concern himself with
sentimentality and how trunks wants
nothing more than to have a father and
recognizing this Goku offers trunks the
in he desires by telling Vegeta he has
to go in with someone however once they
do enter they disappear entirely from
the story almost as if to instill how
disconnected those who leave to train
their truly are from the events that
take place outside this is all to say
that we don't see their training however
when they do eventually emerge from that
room Vegeta says nothing but trunks does
offer a single piece of information that
within just two short months Vegeta
found a way to surpass Super Saiyan to
which Vegeta orders trunks to say no
more it seems the same Prince is careful
not to let his rival his next Target
after cell learn too much and believe it
or not that short interaction that blink
and you missed exchange between Goku
Trunks and Vegeta offered us a sneak
preview of what the future holds for
Vegeta and Trunks in their battle
against cell as I've mentioned across
this video and will continue to do so
this story is filled with a tremendous
amount of nuance and creative excellence
and in order to bring the manga which I
hold in incredibly high regard to life
the anime had a lofty task ahead of them
and so it's important I think to stop
and appreciate the unsung heroes who
helped bring these stories we love so
dearly to life and so we return once
again to the trenches of toy animations
anime adaptation of Dragon Ball Z and
well I say trenches this episode because
while this series sees some of its
biggest positive changeups and gains
this Arc it also marks a difficult point
in the production you see the anime was
very quickly catching up to the manga
which is why there are a large number of
dedicated Filler episodes in this Arc
let alone the entire garlic Jr fidorak
being a thing that exists at the same
time there are several Dragon Ball
movies in production including a TV
special the staff are spread crazy thin
and that resulted in some fascinating
changeups and crazy tight schedules I
think it's most clear to see with the
way Studio Junior's episodes manifested
at this time with maieda busy elsewhere
the people under him had to step into
his shoes on the anime and that truly
kicks off with the katsuyoshi nakutsuru
LED episode of trunks's iconic fight
in spite of nakatsuru's prominence
across the series this is in fact the
second and final episode he directly
supervises and that is a real shame
considering how unbelievably stunning
this is it truly feels like an elevation
of the source material like a Toriyama
illustration come to life thanks to not
only the pristine artwork but the
shading approach itself matching
toriyama's own illustrative style that's
definitely a good thing given some of
the animators on this episode just
straight up aren't very good at drawing
Dragon Ball what's interesting however
is that notoshi shida who was always
under uchiyama's thumb at last house
until now is actually on this episode
and animates frieza's death which is
oh a sign of things to come but more on
that another time mayada's absence
didn't just allow nakutsuru to supervise
it also brought about the debut of Tokyo
IDE in the same position with his
supervisory debut in episode 129 Eda
just cut loose with some of the most
insane looking work it's so distinct
super angular and aggressive in every
sense of the world and it adds some real
Edge to what is one hell of a Vegeta
focused episode when he returns again
later with episode 138 it's a far more
low-key outing and yet iday shows his
versatility here also it's a shame these
were his only two episodes in the
driving seat but he sure did continue to
produce some exceptional work across the
series and went on to become a teacher a
toy animation school and a pivotal part
of Dragon Ball super no less the next to
take the reins on maida's team was a
name introduced in the last episode of
this review series naoki miyahara while
up until this point miyahara had
continued to produce great sequences in
the key animator role this jump to
supervisor came here was kind of
mind-blowing honestly not only are his
corrections to the artwork seriously
awesome looking but the staff under him
on this episode are true All-Stars this
is a landmark of an episode and almost
best of compilation containing some of
the very best this show had to offer
unfortunately the one named missing here
is Hisashi eguchi who left the series
after the 64th episode mentioned in the
Frieza video but it's not all sad as he
actually went on to animate some stuff
in legendary shows like Evangelion
Cowboy Bebop and Ghost in the Shell what
a animal so that brings us to
maida himself and it's not a happy story
to say the least this man was hired all
the way back in the slump era and bless
him he really did his best as toriyama's
work began to evolve and become more
angular and aggressive over time but
this Arc just proved to be too much for
him whether it wore his character
designs or his own Corrections in his
episodes they were just severely lacking
to the point that it was extremely
jarring whenever it would cut to his
best key animators untouched it was time
for him to go and with episode 164 my
Ada Departed the series unfortunately
taking our beloved masaki Sato with him
all however was not lost for in the wild
lands of shindo Productions a young and
ambitious tadiyoshi yamamuro had just
been promoted to animation supervisor
with previous Studio head mitsuo shindo
leaving the show entirely immediately
shindo production episodes became some
of the best looking on the show even if
yamamuro's earliest episodes featured
the biggest foreheads known to humankind
still nothing compared to ebizawa don't
worry King no one's coming for your
Crown episode 157 in particular is
straight up one of the best looking
episodes in Dragon Ball Z's entire
catalog the insane artwork the Fantastic
animation and storyboarding the scale of
this battle is just incredible and it's
clear that the showrunners recognize you
talents as he was given movie duties
with the release of the Broly film and
his designs for it ended up being used
for the TV series proper supplementing
my Ada's work and well the rest is for
the next video of course with Dragon
Ball effectively losing part of a sub
studio with the departure of maieda and
some of his team members toy needed to
bring in some new blood especially with
the series schedule getting Tighter and
Tighter due to the number of movies
being produced introducing Studio
cockpit
[Music]
this Studio's addition to the series
breathes new life into the series
despite their debut episode being fairly
low-key their attention to detail was
crazy impressive turning what would
usually be unremarkable scenes into ones
filled with motion and well by the time
cockpit got their hands on an action
episode they created arguably one of the
most iconic Dragon Ball Z episodes of
all time the action was insanely fast
the posing and movement was incredibly
modern for its time and the artwork was
so unlike anything ever seen on this
series before and when you look at where
some of those key animators on the
episode ended up in the future it's
really no surprise it was so goddamn
good it was something truly special and
this helped to firmly cement Studio
cockpit as Dragon Ball's premium sub
Studio next to the likes of segasha but
cockpit wasn't the only addition along
with them came Studio Carpenter LED By
Yuji hakamada along with a very brief
appearance from a studio called dogakopo
who produced Dragon Ball Z's worst
looking Episode by an absolute Landslide
what is even going on here these three
new additions all had something in
common though they all had a chief
animation supervisor overseeing their
episodes you see in animation production
you have different stages as a key
animator you start with a loose draft
called a layout and an animation
supervisor looks over it and gives you a
correction this is then turned into a
cleaner version called genga which can
also be given a correction and up until
now that was the final stage in Z's
production it was then turned into the
Doga to tie down the correction and then
painted ready for filming this came with
the downside of relying entirely on the
skill of the animation supervisor so if
you are like masayuki uchiyama who
completely shipped the bed in this Arc
drawing some of the worst art you'll
ever see from the show and lamenting the
fact sheeta left him for toei well
that's just how it had to be released
but with a chief supervisor they would
step in after the original supervisor
had done their job to provide further
Corrections and that's precisely what
they did for these new Studios gnoki
miyahara from toei would step into this
role for cockpit and redraw a lot of
matsunaga's work to be far more on
modeled likewise Masahiro shimanuki from
segashe jumped in to prevent dogakobo's
episode from looking like baby's first
Barnard and assisting hakamada while he
got used to Dragon Ball's art style
while the role would only really be
in new Studios to the series it
definitely helped push the quality of
episodes up where they otherwise might
have stood out in not the best of ways
[Music]
it's now time to talk about the best
studio on Z once again sagasha continues
to Simply dominate every episode whether
it's shimanuki or hisada supervising
both have seriously refined their Styles
at this point distilling into absolute
perfection and the animation totally
matches shibanuki once again delivers
with insane impact in vehicle work and
hisada is out here with the most not so
Dynamic angles and poses what's more is
that nokitate has now developed into a
real shining star in his own right
animating some sick battles throughout
this Arc it's really only the old lead
Takeuchi who stands out in uh not a
great way
is that a caveman but what really makes
their episodes special is the director
they're often paired with this is
kazuhito Kikuchi and Holy balls is he an
incredible Talent while his work in the
Frieza Arc was only okay he very quickly
developed into one of Z's finest talents
directing episodes with an impressive
style and confidence that rival Z's
other astronomers director yoshihiro
ueda this man knows how to bore Dynamic
angles and create atmosphere but with
all of that aside no one can compare to
the legend the director who defined a
generation this is shigayasu yamuchi
Dragon Ball's best director and an
industry icon the cell Arc is a tale
filled with genuine horror and Yamauchi
brings this vibe to life in a way not
even Akira Toriyama himself could dream
of doing these sequences are startlingly
good drenched in a variety of
eye-catching colors and reimagined with
captivating imagery that just completely
breaks my brain every time I watch it
every episode he directs in this Arc is
an almost perfect creative
interpretation of his manga counterpart
Yamauchi is the master and with the
likes of Kikuchi anueda on the roster
the seller contains some of the most
consistently well-directed episodes
found in the show and that hard work is
going to be rewarded as Dragon Ball sees
its biggest production shakeup next week
in this production Deep dive but let's
not get ahead of ourselves for this hack
we've yet to explore the consequences of
Vegeta and trunks's time in the chamber
oh
Super Vegeta versus Cell this is another
moment that stands as a monument for
many Vegeta fans to everything they love
about the character sudden reappearances
with a shiny new form against an
arrogant foe he's full of bravado and a
level of confidence that borders on the
theatrical there's something so very
entertaining watching Vegeta contend
with someone he knows he is stronger
than in every conceivable measure but
again keeping in mind the broader
context of the story at hand here what I
loved about this Super Vegeta unveiling
is its significance for Vegeta as a
character and what it represents this is
Vegeta's moment to secure his victory
against this monster yes but also to be
the fighter in this series the best the
most impressive the strongest and at
first it seems to work he Powers up to
tremendous Fanfare cell Powers up to but
it's not enough there's even a rare
instance of moment to moment paneling in
the manga that mirrors Goku's fight
against Frieza Cell punches Vegeta in
the face Vegeta eats it and slowly
raises his head back with a smirk quote
I guess that's all there is much like
the Android 19 fight this is Vegeta
having the time of his life once again
he's reaffirmed to himself that his
approach is the way and at this present
moment in time he is in fact the
strongest warrior in the entire universe
which you would think at this moment
would be enough to satiate Vegeta's ego
right
foreign
[Music]
cool man if Cell wasn't part saying I'd
swear he was the luckiest creature in
all of creation for uttering such a
perfect cocktail of words to Vegeta at
this moment in time perfectly timed
against krillin's own internal moral
struggles concerning what right he has
to take Android 18's life at the moment
choosing to not shut her down granting
her a freedom cell never would but in
doing so almost Dooms her to that very
same fate regardless and upon reflection
there are even more attributes to this
fight that share similarities between
Goku's battle with Frieza on Namek and I
honestly think it's rather fitting
allowing cell to land the very first
punch the paneling is remarkably similar
as I said to the beam Goku allows Frieza
to land on him but even more aptly
allowing cell to reach 100 so to speak
but the difference here is that if you
compare Goku's fight with Frieza and his
reasoning sure there's an element of
Vegeta and Goku's makeup that's simply
too curious to pass up such a chance to
see what this power is like but
underneath that Vegeta betrays his
biggest flaw once again his insecurity
Goku wanted to utterly defeat Frieza
there and then at his strongest with no
excuses to get revenge for Krillin in
Revenge he ultimately couldn't bring
himself to claim but Vegeta is doing
this to prove that he's the strongest
once again to stroke his own ego and for
no other reason
foreign
[Music]
countless times in this story leading up
to Vegeta's time in the room he reminds
us and reaffirms to himself that Goku is
still the Target that he will defeat him
best him kill him it seems that whenever
he fails or is alone Vegeta is consumed
with thoughts of Kakarot and his rivalry
with him a one-sided rivalry that blinds
the Saiyan Prince to what his actual
roadblocks are a roadblock that has now
taken the shape of cell a creature that
in this moment exists as a direct result
of his faults and ego an entity that no
matter how much Vegeta Puffs out his
chest he'll never be able to best it's a
terrific metaphor one that Vegeta fights
to his last breath trying to prove wrong
and in a dramatic and impressive show of
force that amounts to nothing more than
vanity Vegeta ignites his most
devastating attack the final flash
Golding cell to take it head on and once
he does
sell toys with the prince before smiling
right into his face shattering his
perception once again this time in a
more devastating fashion than a team did
there's a moment in this Arc where
Vegeta Furious after seeing everyone
surpass what he once considered to be
the ultimate power in the universe the
Super Saiyan exposes his displeasure
with this reality and even asks
rhetorically to himself if Kakarot would
agree it's noted by trunks moments after
they both left the chamber that Vegeta
didn't require a full year to surpass
Super Saiyan to find a way to break
through that proverbial glass ceiling
you see Vegeta only required two months
and not a full year however the subtle
implication nestled in that impressive
statement is that after two months
Vegeta no matter how hard he tried hit a
wall a wall he could not overcome with
torturous training alone a wall he is
faced with here once again
and as the once powerful super saiyan
glow Fades from Vegeta's now limp and
unconscious body our eyes become
transfixed on the actions of one young
Saiyan from the future however as all of
this is kicking off I'm reminded of the
words of advice Goku offered trunks
right before he left for the battlefield
with his father handing him sensu Beans
Goku said don't Press Your Luck bail out
if it gets too dangerous ever since this
fight started to turn against Vegeta
we've been given reason to believe that
trunks has been hiding yet unseen levels
of strength and power untapped reserves
he's hidden away from his father for
fear it would upset him and I don't
think a single character Choice better
encapsulates trunks's personality than
the choice he made right here despite
what Goku told him despite the situation
becoming dire the young trunks desperate
to develop a connection with the father
he never had chose instead to protect
the pride of his father than to further
risk worsening his already tenuous
relationship with him it's a massively
Reckless decision made by the young and
naive son of the Saiyan Prince and one
that speaks to his character profoundly
and it is here at this moment of
Reckless anticipation during the
confrontation with cell that may very
well determine the fate of the entire
universe it is here Akira toriyama's
narrative sleight of hand begins to
truly reveal itself within the room of
spirit and time
the room of spirit and time much like
snake way was a very fun visual concept
that captured my imagination as a kid
this notion that our heroes could get an
entire Year's worth of training done in
a single day just sounded Fantastical to
me and once Trunks and Vegeta set foot
inside my enthusiasm and interest
reached a fever pitch what must it be
like to train inside this bizarre and
magical chamber I thought and
interestingly that's when Toriyama
closed the door and we never really got
to see inside properly we never got to
see any training why firstly I should
point out that any and all footage we
received in the anime of trunks and
Vegeta's training was total filler in
the manga all we see is the emotional
impression both characters have once
they enter and then total radio silence
in fact Akira Toriyama leverages our
lack of knowledge concerning Trunks and
Vegeta's training to build tension
outside as Goku wonders what's taking
them so long however that wasn't the
only reason we as viewers were left in
the dark concerning this chamber there
was another much more important reason
ever since the beginning of Dragon Ball
Goku has been our Rock our Safe Harbor
in a story full of confusing mystical
and ever worsening realities and
typically in storytelling a useful trick
authors use to bond us to their main
characters is this shared sense of
experience a feeling that we as an
audience and this character are on the
same page equally confused equally
familiar and in the know it doesn't
always have to be this way but it
certainly helps to establish a rapport
and bond with us and them and Goku from
the outset was designed with this in
mind upon our first introduction to the
story we meet Goku and through our brief
introduction to the character we
understand him completely but not the
wider world and having grown up in
almost total isolation himself Goku was
very much in the same boat as us and
thus asked all the same questions we're
asking ourselves at home what are Dragon
Balls what's capsule Corp technology
what are all of these martial arts
philosophies and through receiving these
answers and growing alongside this
character we feel that much more
invested and bonded to him and while he
started to feel different ever since the
Saiyan Saga he and us have always been
on the same page asking all of the same
questions what is Otherworld snake way
King Kai where is Namek who is Frieza
and the list goes on and on however in
this Arc something happened following
his defeat to Android 19 the Goku we
know and love might have returned but
the dynamic we shared with him did not
awaking on Roshi's Island amidst the
chaos of the plot he looked strangely
cam almost confusingly so because at
that moment Goku knew something we
didn't and as he uttered his plan the
room of spirit and time our shared sense
of understanding only further evaporated
with this character the naive young boy
that had no idea how to tell the
difference between boys and girls in the
beginning the kid who was socially
illiterate in the most innocent of ways
has since transformed into a much more
sophisticated grown man capable not just
of picking up the subtleties of social
situations but leveraging his ability to
navigate them effectively in order to
smooth over complicated relationships a
former student that has long since
graduated looking to Foster the Next
Generation a strong capable Warrior that
knows far more about this world now than
even we do and so with that explanation
out of the way it should be obvious why
Toriyama decided to shift Goku's
character now why he chose to keep us
all in the dark concerning the room of
spirit and time he kept us in the dark
because Gohan was in the dark too so for
the length of this entire fight from the
moment Vegeta landed on the island in
front of cell we have been seeing Goku
and Gohan training getting a peek behind
the curtain and while for most of
Vegeta's fight it may have seemed all
but a requisite inclusion given that
Goku is you know the main character it
is the surprising reveal with trunks's
fight that reveals the incredibly clever
point of it all from the get-go cell has
reached his perfect form Vegeta is
totally unconscious and Trunks standing
between the Earth and certain
destruction sees this as a chance for
him to rise to the lofty occasion to
right the wrongs of his past mistakes to
finally prove to everyone and himself
that much like his father surpassing the
Super Saiyan barrier that much like Goku
being the savior of Earth and like Gohan
in his timeline saving his world he too
can make a difference but what trunks at
first saw as This Magnificent
opportunity for Redemption a chance to
demonstrate that he's a capable Warrior
now served as perhaps the most oppressed
and sobering Monument to his commutative
failings in this Arc and it's all made
that much more effective thanks to the
complimenting scenes with Goku and Gohan
in the room perhaps in ways you might
not ever have appreciated before
foreign
right before this fight begins trunks is
exceptionally certain evidenced through
his demeanor how he orders Krillin to
take his father home and give him the
last sense of being because he won't
need it and the story does a lot to
really sell us on the secret power from
the get-go Krillin himself mentions his
Keen sense of people's underlying Powers
even if they're way out of his league
and specifically calls out trunks as
having been more prepared than Vegeta
was between Vegeta's Cockiness and the
vote of sage Confidence from one of the
most storied martial artists in the
entire cast everything is pointing to
trunks pulling out all the stops here
and maybe winning but as the fight
Begins the parallel story in the room of
spirit and time reveals a very different
perspective a set of cutaways that are
without question the most narratively
important creatively Rich cutaways the
entire series sees
foreign
much like Vegeta Goku entered the room
with a similar ambition to surpass the
Super Saiyan State and transcend his
limitations we never get to see trunks
or Vegeta attain this level so we
enthusiastically watch on wide-eyed as
Goku meditates only to then suddenly
unlock Vegeta's ascended State otherwise
known as Super Saiyan great too but even
more miraculously seconds later he
transcends that again to something even
more powerful super saiyan grade 3 the
exact same impressive transformation
trunks is boasting currently against
cell this moment initially feels like
Goku being Goku and catching off to the
likes of trunks grade 3 with ease except
on the very next page
oh come on
Goku achieving that form wasn't simply a
game of ketchup but a revelation of
trunks's mistake
throughout the entirety of Vegeta and
trunks's Rumble with the big bumble cell
Goku and Gohan in the room of spirit and
time have acted as an up until now
incredibly sneaky and clever parallel to
the events unfolding outside of the
chamber the cutaways themselves are
compelling in their own right which
helps smuggle them aboard this big
reveal but with a bit of hindsight it's
rather apparent how one-to-one these two
stories unfold consistently juxtaposed
against one another the very second
Vegeta begins powering up against cell
we are immediately interrupted with the
B plot of Gohan and Goku entering the
room and almost immediately as the two
walk in Goku makes this his mission
statement quote I'm going to reach the
state beyond the Super Saiyan I'm going
to be more powerful than anyone but I
want you Gohan to be more powerful than
me throughout this beat plot we see
their Journey largely through Gohan's
eyes once again the presentation of Goku
has shifted he is seemingly transcended
the state of main character the position
of audiences point of view and instead
the person in that room who now shares
the audience's level of knowledge and
mystery is Gohan and as the fight
between Vegeta and cell rages on outside
trunks watching on as his proud father
does well to even barely recognize him
each successive cutaway further drives
home the difference between the two
father-son approaches here in multiple
scenes during Vegeta's fight Gohan is
shown struggling to achieve Super Saiyan
struggling to live up to the
expectations and goals his father has
set for him pushing himself impossibly
hard to break the threshold and become a
useful training partner finally for his
father but immediately the difference in
Dynamic with this pair compared to
Vegeta and Trunks is night and day Goku
never allows him to feel like his
inability to meet the goal is an instant
failure but instead a necessary part of
the journey quote nobody is good at it
overnight be patient you were doing
pretty well there it just takes more
work that's all let's take a break I'll
cut your hair it's getting Shaggy every
perceived setback or failure Gohan
experiences Goku is right there
responding with encouragement and
kindness however conversely once this
line is uttered by trunks following his
humiliation at the hands of cell
suddenly the relevance of all these
cutaways makes a lot more sense
foreign
ly all of his effort into nurturing his
son to bring out his potential Vegeta
left trunks completely out to dry a more
experienced warrior in every right he
was the mentor trunks needed as they
spent a year in that room together but
that never happened they shared
absolutely nothing with one another
other than the space they occupied
together and after a year of forced
proximity the very best recognition
Vegeta can offer trunks is at best a
backhanded compliment quote I'll tell
you something that will really shock you
there's a guy named trunks over there
he's almost as powerful as me a guy
named trunks not his son and moreover
the idea of trunks somehow being almost
as powerful as he must be shocking to
anyone referring to himself as Super
Vegeta it's clear that despite Goku's
efforts to create space for Vegeta to
get to know his son and vice versa his
mission in that room was nothing but one
of self-obsessed vanity a project he set
on to build a monument to his Own
Strength one that cell himself tears
down with Joy Brick by Brick Crack by
crack leaving Vegeta when all is said
and done with nothing but his useless
pride in tatters and throughout it all
we are being shown glimpses of the
genius in Goku's own approach the slow
and steady nurturing that is happening
with his son in the background as
Vegeta's hubris comes crashing down
around him and the ramifications of that
reverberate out as the inexperienced
trunks faces the consequence of his
impetuousness
foreign
some way out of all of this
trunks has failed a number of times in
this Arc always in the name of doing the
right thing he sets out to change the
future for the better but his lack of
understanding of time travel itself
leads to him assuming Frieza arriving on
Earth before Goku was an anomaly to be
corrected causing him to alter the
events of the timeline within seconds of
his arrival he tries his best to stop
the activation of 17 and 18 but his
ignorance of both Dr Duro as well as the
Warriors he has Allied himself with
leads to a complete failure yet again
when the idea of surpassing Super Saiyan
is mentioned the very notion seems to
baffle trunks in all his years surviving
in his future the thought had never even
occurred to him time and time again
despite his Incredible strength for his
age trunks fails never living up to the
lofty expectations he was established
under with his introduction but this
fight this is the culmination of all
that the ultimate humiliation against
his youthful ignorance and with the
juxtaposition of Goku's careful
nurturing and training of Gohan it
becomes clear that this one more than
any mistake that came before is not on
trunks to begin with this one is
Vegeta's failure in this battle where
trunks wanted to prove that he wasn't a
failure that he could be the hero his
timeline and mother needs
he failed and all because his father
never took the time to advise or nurture
him in the same way Goku taught and
nurtured his own son and I suppose
according to Vegeta sentiment is nothing
more than a distraction on the road to
ultimate power so I guess that's
consistent but in a true twist of fate
the consequences of these actions are
brought to a screeching halt because
cell doesn't kill trunks
[Music]
and this is where I think things go from
interesting to exceptionally interesting
and between now and the conclusion of
this video I will be making the case
that this tournament cell proposes is
not only the culmination of this Arc not
just the culmination of the Gohan
character but the culmination of Goku
and the entire series up until this
point and frankly I think it's a
magnificent Triumph of a conclusion in
what is objectively the result of
toriyama's third narrative pivot egged
on by his Saiyan genetic Excel expresses
he wants to start something called the
Cell Games the announcement of which is
even more chilling than I remembered
there's something so unsettling about
how cheery and matter-of-factly cell
says and I quote and in the end when I'm
the Victor I will kill every single
human being on this planet I'll
methodically come after every last one
of you and I'll watch your faces twist
with fear
what a horrifyingly personal threat to
each individual person alive on the
planet and now off the back of that
stunningly and horrifyingly announced
event just like he did when we were in
the pits of negativity with Frieza as he
stole Vegeta's will to fight
kiritoriyama once again breaks out
another rare instance of mid-chapter
narration cells broadcast filled the
Earth's population with overwhelming
fear the world had no faith in the
military or the police marginalized
after years of Peace the world had no
faith in its Champions but the world had
forgotten that long ago there lived a
little boy who fought the great Demon
King Piccolo the world had forgotten the
warrior that had turned against the
threat of the Saiyans and Frieza the
world had forgotten Son Goku
there's something special about what
happens next during cell's revelation of
the Cell Games he makes mention of a
specific tournament I loved from early
Dragon Ball called the Tenkaichi Budokai
for the purposes of the Cell Games he
wanted to emulate that event in its
presentation and rules however for me
this looming tournament inspired by the
contest that helped to Define Dragon
Ball's past carries with it a special
significance a significance that
stretches far beyond the confines of
this one Arc and one that can be felt
everywhere in this story because this
has been the longest running story told
in Dragon Ball's history
as fans of the series we all understand
where the story ultimately goes for Goku
and fittingly Goku in these chapters
follows an intentional and somewhat
nostalgic path revisiting characters
that help to shape who he was expressing
concerns he otherwise hadn't so directly
before
emphasizing his role as the Earth's
Defender visibly angered by the
military's attack on sale leading to all
their Collective deaths a mistake Goku
solves by bringing dende to Earth as the
new Guardian thanks to his unique powers
and what's more is the news broadcast
following the military's defeat talks of
their hope hope that just like a young
boy rose up to defeat the great Demon
King Piccolo there too will be another
great hero that will stand up when no
one else can for cell and as we're
reading this suddenly It all becomes
clear this is written to be Goku's
ending a snapshot in time where he
passes the torch to the Next Generation
to someone he knows deserves it his son
in the past we got to experience the
21st 22nd and 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai is
as three parts to what I expressed at
the time were the greatest story Dragon
Ball had ever told a story centered
around the progression of the next
generation one of passing the torch
responsibility and heroism a story
centered around Son Goku expressed in
three parts as he Grew Older after
leaving the room Goku made a series of
announcements but the most surprising
had to have been his refusal to go back
into the chamber another time surrounded
by the likes of Trunks Vegeta and
Piccolo this seems like the obvious
choice however this sudden refusal for
me echoed a few wise words offered
during the lead up to his very first
tournament quote move well study well
play well eat well rest well that is the
turtle hermit way as Goku points out in
this scene both he and Gohan have
already put in the work and he refuses
to rob their bodies of the rest it so
sorely needs and when you look at this
section with Goku through the lens of
his past there are plenty of poetic
references in this Arc Goku has done his
best to Foster Gohan's talents and in
this impending fight that Goku knows he
will eventually lose he plans on
quitting much the same way roshi bowed
out to make room for the Next Generation
in the 22nd Tenkaichi Budokai Goku 2
will resign after feeling as though it
is finally his time to allow someone
else a turn there are so many more
things to that fight and indeed
references to the 23rd tenkaichipurikai
elsewhere but before we ultimately dive
into the final fight of this Arc I
thought necessary to outline what have
been surprisingly poignant chapters for
Toriyama to pen chapters he wrote This
Way intentionally to on some level
communicate to us the emotional gravity
behind what's about to happen the anime
only further drives this home showcasing
dare I say the best Filler episodes the
entire series sees Son Gohan having his
own encounters with the evils of
humanity and an encounter with the long
since forgotten mercenary Tau pie a
birthday celebration and the reminiscing
that comes along with that every single
filler episode is spent furthering this
moment these 10 days of Peace before the
Cell Games and right before Goku flies
off to the games Chichi asks him for two
things
to come back alive and to not allow
Gohan to fight two promises that
ultimately prove impossible for him to
keep
foreign
Goku vs Cell I might have just spoken on
this battle in my lead up analysis to it
but there's far more at play narratively
in this fight than simply its ending and
a surprising amount in fact as I touched
on a moment ago there's been a palpable
poignancy and emotion in the writing of
this Arc so much so that a hundred
percent of the comedic relief in this
back quarter comes entirely from a
certain champion of the world that will
be receiving much more attention in the
next part but the first aspect of this
fight that comes to my attention was the
uncomfortable kinship acknowledged and
brought to the Forefront between Goku
and cell having just spoken of the
virtues Goku embodies I'm sure many of
you might be confused as to what I'm
alluding to here specifically well in
this fight they both acknowledge how
fulfilling and exciting this occasion is
simply because of how comparatively
strong they both are how evenly matched
the contest is putting the consequences
to one side if only for a moment to
enjoy the sport of it all not just for
the battle-hungry Goku but for the
equally battle hungry cell a creation
meant for his destruction that in a
Twist of irony is arguably the perfect
opponent Goku has always yearned for
naturally Goku snaps out of this
situationship he has with cell once the
Earth is seemingly targeted by cells
Kamehameha forcing Goku to bait his
blast upwards during this battle Goku
pulls out every trick he can muster
against the mighty cell including a
devastatingly powerful and amazingly
cathartic Kamehameha with his Instant
Transmission but it's still all to no
effect and as his stamina started to
wane and Goku's time when the
battlefield came to an end I started to
contemplate an interesting possibility
Toriyama may have been trying to
establish with this encounter having
compared their similar levels of
strength their instinctive motivations
in combat part of me believes that
Toriyama wanted to establish cell as a
metaphorical stand-in for Goku once he
eventually quits a choice that once made
would mean that in order for Gohan to
become the new defender of the Earth
he would need to defeat an enemy that's
slightly stronger than his father with
that same hunger for combat and once
Goku tosses seldat senzu Bean
thematically Gohan is not only facing
off against the fighter that holds
similar power and hunger to his father
but one that additionally can be seen as
the personification of that poison
within Goku's character for while Goku
may have been following the same path
roshi led him down with Gohan
intentionally or otherwise mirroring the
events of the 21st and 22nd Tenkaichi
Budokai as we approach what Goku no
doubt anticipates would be Gohan's 23rd
Tenkaichi Budokai moment one that will
see him crowned as the Earth's number
one Defender
that same poison surfaces in Goku a
poison that's blinded him to the truth
that's been staring him right in the
face since Gohan was born
[Music]
Gohan vs Cell
in my view this fight has three rather
distinct phases with each phase offering
its own specific and emphatic conclusion
that complements the subject of its face
and unlike other final fights I've
covered in this series this fight is
remarkably short typically within Dragon
Ball the final fight of these more
serious arcs are quite extensive
exploring the themes of the material in
a more thorough manner so why does this
fight feel much more on the short side
well because the fight itself isn't the
payoff the fight isn't the climax to
this story that's been told at least not
entirely in my opinion unlike Frieza or
Vegeta cell doesn't represent anything
as profound or complicated to Gohan or
Goku specifically he represents
something sure but his personality and
character is far less pivotal to the
main characters than others I've touched
on cell's main function in the story
therefore is to provide a target for Our
Heroes to focus on a stage for which to
perform their acts upon the main story
of this Arc is shared between Gohan and
Goku and the ending to this story starts
with a mistake
Goku's mistake in my previous two videos
I connected them through the themes they
shared in the Saiyan Saga I tried to
explore the message of that Arc that
being the differences we are criticized
for can be our greatest strengths in
other words the differences that existed
within Goku compared to the likes of his
brother and Vegeta who thought they
themselves were Model Saiyans those
differences they saw in Goku enabled him
to learn key techniques and form lasting
friendships that ultimately made the
difference in that Arc following on from
that the Frieza Arc stretched those
themes and ideas to their natural
extremes forcing us and Goku to contend
with questions like what happens when
you encounter a foe your friends cannot
help you best who threatens your very
family someone that forces you into a
corner to fight with Instinct forcing
you to contend with what you are instead
of who you are since then as many of you
might have noticed I've refrained from
continuing that thematic through line
for this video until now
once again the cell Saga extends these
themes explored in the prior two arcs
and pushes them even further Goku
despite being cornered on Namek still
gave Frieza an out he didn't want to
kill him his upbringing helped to Define
who he was and so because Goku LED this
life he expects a lot of His Son Gohan
and in a way this mistake this
misjudgment takes Goku full circle back
to the Saiyan Saga in the same way
Vegeta and Raditz expected Goku to be
one way Goku too misjudged what Gohan
was and placed him in a circumstance
that while he Goku would have loved it
Gohan didn't and what's more is it
terrified him
for the entire series Gohan is framed as
totally different to his father his
introduction totally mirrors Goku's
where Goku was introduced demonstrating
martial arts and saving Bulma Gohan is
introduced by politely and anxiously
introducing himself before being
kidnapped Goku's first on-screen
training was with roshi the Earth's hero
while Gohan was forced to train against
his will with the earth's greatest
villain at the time it should have been
clear to Goku that Gohan was totally
different to him and during the fight
with cell this is all shown to him and
us over and over
[Applause]
[Music]
but the thing is this mistake is largely
kept under wraps for quite a while as
Gohan begins to fight with cell there is
a feeling a presumption by the reader
that this plan is destined for Success
since leaving the room of spirit and
time Goku who we know is a tactical
genius in battle has been completely
confident in this planet and while we
may have once known Gohan as a skittish
scared little kid he's grown a lot since
then face the likes of Vegeta the Ginyu
Force and even frees ahead on and now
coming off a year of somewhat secret
training with his father there's the
feeling that this will be the final step
in his journey to become a hero
the hero but Gohan our Newfound point of
view figures this out just about as
quickly as we do and reveals to us the
underlying emotion within him that we
are all not privy to he knows his
father's plan will work but he doesn't
really want it to because he doesn't
like fighting when this scenario is
pushed to its natural conclusion Gohan
will almost certainly erupt in a fit of
rage and the gap between their
respective strengths will completely
close but this is not something Gohan
wants to happen in the first place these
fits of powerful rage are not a point of
Pride for Gohan but a weakness instead
and worse still telling cell this
doesn't scare him off because of course
it wouldn't as we've said before cell in
this instance is a de facto stand-in of
Goku the thought of an opponent erupting
into rage and becoming as strong as cell
is about as perfect as a promise he
could possibly ask for cell says and I
quote did you think I would get cold if
you told me that you still think like a
kid now I want to see you mad a cell
takes things up a notch and begins to
absolutely Pummel the ever-loving life
out of Gohan in an attempt to make him
angry the true Crux of Goku's mistake is
revealed and it goes even deeper than
Gohan not being battle hungry like his
father as Piccolo lays out plainly soon
[Music]
Goku Mr Gohan's previous fits of Rage as
an extension of his fighting prowess an
additional level to his strength but
that's not what they ever were Gohan was
only ever pushed to those fits of Rage
as an involuntary painful knee-driven
attempt to protect others looking back
as far as the beginning of this series
The only time Gohan has ever really
erupted as a self-defense mechanism is
when Piccolo chocked him at a mountain
as a toddler every other instance of his
rage-driven power was in service of
someone else a friend someone in need
anyone but himself Outburst that came
when there was no one left to protect
those he loved but this time everyone is
right there safely watching from the
hills his own father perhaps capable of
at least hurting cells standing by as
Gohan is beaten to the ground
he isn't angry he's just hurt and
frightened now of course by the time
Goku truly comes to terms with the
situation he's put his son in it's too
late it doesn't take long for cell to
realize that Gohan is not the type of
person to react to his own harm and so
self begets his little cell Juniors to
Pummel all of Gohan's friends and family
a cell keeps him out of the fight
himself and as a result Goku's strategic
plan to leverage Gohan has completely
Fallen apart with more than sell at play
someone is going to die before Gohan
erupts whether it be himself Yamcha
Krillin so many of the onlookers have
died once already and dende's new dragon
balls are still not capable of Reviving
someone twice
when I first read this moment I honestly
felt as though it was strange to have 16
be the one to offer this advice to Gohan
but upon reflection in truth it seems
almost perfect the two of them sharing
this moment together not only in terms
of the Thematic power of having a
literal machine delivery speech on the
value of Life humanity and the moral
obligation to protect those things but
also a person created in the image of
his father designed to possess not only
great power but literal explosive
capabilities inside of him a person who
was ultimately seen as a failure Jew to
his timid nature however now 16 is
stripped of all his weapons of Terror no
more Rockets no more bombs no more
offensive tools at his disposal All That
Remains are these timid qualities
qualities that make 16 the perfect
person to be speaking to Gohan at this
moment at the end of it all much like
Gohan it isn't 16 himself that he speaks
about protecting 16 isn't concerned in
the slightest with his own well-being In
This Moment despite his current
circumstances instead he asks Gohan to
protect the ones which he loves those
who cannot protect themselves to protect
the animals and nature that he cares for
there couldn't have been a more perfect
request Nate Catalyst to appeal to and
ignite the sleeping Beast Within Sun
Gohan
[Music]
together
move on
to him
[Music]
protect them for me
I don't think I need to say much on what
fate befalls the cell Juniors they are
completely and utterly dismantled by
Gohan without so much as a second
thought defeats that were depicted as
puffs of smoke in the anime are
presented far more graphic in the manga
with their eyes and limbs flying
everywhere upon contact with the
clinical and now cerebral Sun Gohan from
the moment this young man snapped the
battle was already lost for sound every
single interaction from this point on is
cell coming to terms with just how in
over his head he truly is even
destroying his cell Juniors which were
clearly similar in strength to him is
enough to anger and unnerve him as cell
powers to his maximum Gohan is
completely unimpressed
3. solitary blows that's all it takes
extended in the anime but in the manga
it's emphatically clear just how
cell is now deeply injured beyond
anything Goku managed in just a few
Choice blows but it is at this point
that we see the true difference between
Goku and cell where Goku when faced
against a foe he can't possibly measure
up to responds with unwavering
determination to overcome the obstacle
and reach New Heights cell completely
breaks down and cracks under the
pressure maybe it's those genetics from
Frieza within him that elicit such a
scared childlike response much the same
way Frieza when finally met with someone
stronger than him petulantly immediately
resorted to blowing up the Planet Cell 2
takes to the skies and charges an earth
ending Kamehameha but once again all
involved underestimate the strength that
lay dormant within Gohan
[Music]
thank you but alas Nothing Gold Can Stay
a cell continues to fall apart in
disbelief a dormant poison is revealed
within the young man where his father
fell victim to his deep-seated desire to
fight stronger opponents to reach New
Heights at nearly all costs Gohan 2 has
a poison within him a tendency it would
seem to exact a thorough Vengeance
against those who wronged his loved ones
it's a sight of Gohan we've never really
seen before given every other fit of
rage before this was essentially an
unconscious Outburst but it's a wrinkle
that certainly makes a lot of sense now
if turning super saiyan was enough to
push Goku the most kind-hearted and
peaceful soul in this story to sending
his son away while he still has his
senses left imagine what Gohan driven
purely by righteous Fury must have going
through his head as he is capable of
bringing the utterly irredeemable cell
to his knees before him it is such a
natural conclusion of all elements
involved both with Gohan's character and
the ferocity that Super Saiyan begets as
was mentioned volumes Ago by Vegeta and
while for the time being Gohan may be
capable of toying with his prey
continually trouncing an inflated cell
even causing him to vomit out poor
Android 18. it is this poison within him
that will ultimately lead to a downfall
an ultimate price that only one person
can pay
foreign
[Music]
despite knowing that his son could have
put him away despite screaming and
pleading with him to put this threat to
bed while he still has a chance knowing
this terrifying entity would start to
feel desperate at one point or another
despite all of that
this moment is remarkably still
quiet even
there's no resentment disappointment or
I told you so's just silent acceptance
kindness
and love unbeknownst to Goku he still
had one last act as the Earth's number
one Defender to carry out
one last lesson to offer his son that he
could not be more proud of a lesson he
offers him through action a lesson that
occurs during a snapshot in time where
both he and his son totally understand
each other Goku knows that Gohan isn't
him he's still only an 11 year old child
and right now he needs his father more
than anything else
he needs someone who can turn an
impossible situation like this around
and fix his mistake during the 23rd
Tenkaichi Budokai Goku walked into and
confronted that dire set of
circumstances with an unshakable level
of confidence composure and not to
mention humility and within that
tournament as the final fight that
determined the fate of the world took
place no matter how bad everything got
no matter the condition of the Ring his
body or the desire of his friends to
lend a hand
Goku not only wanted to stop Piccolo but
he wanted and needed to do it alone so
that he could win the tournament and not
only is Gohan not capable of that
unshakable mindset but I don't think
anyone in this story is and with that
acknowledgment Goku places his hand on
Cell turns his head with the promises
Chichi asked him to keep weighing
heavily in his mind
he smiles and says
you did well Gohan I'm proud of you tell
your mom I'm sorry
that is Goku's ending his definitive
ending that was intended by Akira
Toriyama all of the emotional and
nostalgic lead up to this moment one
that tried to convince us that Goku was
yet again teeing up for another
cataclysmic Battle of good versus evil
has instead been revealed to be one of
the most touching and fitting send-offs
any character could have hoped for
however unlike every other Arc prior
this is no longer Goku's story it's
Gohan's and now with his final lesson
having been learned it's time for him to
stand unshakable when no one else can
[Applause]
[Music]
as I've alluded to on a number of
occasions while a large amount of focus
was placed on Goku and Gohan's
relationship Vegeta and Trunks have
contributed a captivating and somewhat
difficult to experience Story one that
felt as though it was destined for
tragedy one that might despite
everything they've gone through end with
trunks returning home unfulfilled and
Vegeta returning to the status quo never
to concern himself with sentiment ever
again but neither of these things happen
from the very beginning of Vegeta's
Journey he's demonstrated a cold and
harsh Demeter a philosophy of Might
makes right and if he isn't the
mightiest then he needs to become the
mightiest no matter what stands in his
way everything from killing your own
teammate to scolding others from making
the save on him instead of the Strategic
play is permissible sure his mindset
cost him once or twice but you can't
argue with the results he became a Super
Saiyan a Super Saiyan that pushed past
the level of Super Saiyan before anyone
else and if he can stay this passionate
if he can stay ruthless cold-hearted
focus on himself and avoid sentence
foreign
and in this Arc Goku and Vegeta both
learned to appreciate their children for
who they really are and unfortunately it
took extreme circumstances for them to
come to terms with that throughout this
Arc Vegeta has been a belligerent and
egotistical sociopath the likes of which
threatened the Earth and is one of the
main reasons we have to endure this
fight at all simply put while Goku
thought he knew who his son was but was
mistaken Vegeta simply convinced himself
and others that he couldn't have cared
less and when all the chips were down
when Goku and Vegeta were backed into a
corner of their own creation mind you
that's when the ball dropped when Vegeta
arrived in the battlefield and watched
the action unfold you could tell that
there was a tremendous amount of fear in
his eyes body and words looking at cell
but when this happened when cell took
from him something he never knew he
valued
his body moved almost without order
there was no more strategy there was no
more pride in himself no more ego and
vanity for a brief moment in time
instead his body moved to avenge and
attacked the murderer of his only son
and unfortunately sentiment on this
occasion caused him
hello visitor
it's remarkable how despite this final
battle really only concerning two
powerful entities Gohan and cell Trunks
Vegeta and Goku all have a role to play
in the big finale feeling as resonant As
It ultimately becomes having returned
from the future to help save Goku to
ensure that Goku gets the heart medicine
and makes it to the battlefield to
change their future despite things
changing considerably trunks is forced
to watch on as Goku ends up being one of
the main reasons cell becomes as
powerful and dangerous as he ultimately
does with the last thing he sees right
before he dies being the cold Embrace of
death brought on by the Tyrant he tried
and failed to kill SEL said it himself
and I quote
Son Goku didn't defeat me at all he just
made me better in response to this
Vegeta following his first selfish act
he's ever attempted ends up needing to
be saved in a fashioned that almost
perfectly mirrors the save Gohan offered
him against raccoon all those years ago
only this time it's different
this time Vegeta understands he doesn't
scold Gohan for not using this as an
opportunity to kill cell
he simply says sorry and this resounding
and phenomenal build up to what is the
best beam struggle in the series
sees on one side cell now having
returned more powerful than ever having
removed any and all hope of anyone else
helping in this battle and Gohan now
much like his future self reduced to
only using one arm it's an incredible
moment that only gets better the closer
you look at its outstanding writing
everyone is cursing their own
powerlessness Vegeta's uncharacteristic
apology even suggests a level of
hopelessness itself and as Sal Powers up
his solar system destroying Kamehameha
Gohan 2 resigns himself to death that is
until
no matter how bad things got against
Piccolo in the 23rd Tenkaichi Budokai
Goku never gave up he never stopped
believing he was going to come out
Victorious with his energy bordering on
empty in every last one of his limbs out
of commission he the Earth's Defender
never lost hope but Gohan
Gohan needs reassurance he's not like
his father he's not able to do what he
did but with three good limbs left and
half his key still remaining Goku's not
about to let his son throw in the title
just yet Goku not only steps in to save
his son with his sacrifice but he stands
in behind him every step of the way in
this final struggle for the fate of the
universe this is a moment that
demonstrates the payoff to Gohan's
character Arc yes but it is also the
moment Goku truly demonstrates that he
understands and wants to support his son
a support that even death itself cannot
stand in his way from offering this is
son Goku's true strength quote you can
do it believe in yourself one last time
show me the power we made together
foreign the anime extends this scene
quite a lot extending it to include
others who can help but in actuality
this moment of pushing himself alongside
his father that's the payoff that's the
climax and because of that the struggle
itself is so much shorter than you might
recall in the manga but it does include
one last piece of icing for us to enjoy
as readers and viewers it also pays off
the arc Vegeta has been going on in this
story finding meaning in being a support
player without which Gohan may have
never won without in every sense of the
word Vegeta's story in this Arc is as
important as Goku and gohans and without
Vegeta finding that confidence within
himself to assist when all the chips
were down this fight could have ended
very differently
[Music]
okay this Arc has taken us a very long
way more so than pretty much any other
Arc before it it covers a span of years
following the journeys of characters
that change drastically over the course
of it all it is a remarkable Journey
much more so than I had previously given
a credit for and at the end of it all
All That Remains is Son Gohan lying on
the ground with a smile in his face and
Son Goku watching from the Afterlife
with an even bigger smile if you can
believe that as Gohan and Co fly off to
recuperate and Satan begins to work on
taking credit for it all Vegeta finds
himself at an impasse fully aware of how
outclassed he was by both men and the
sun family
all he can seem to really care about is
that Kakarot is gone
how dare you die like that he says
having gone through a journey of his own
and having relinquished himself to an
act of selflessness at the end of it all
Vegeta is left with nothing no Kakarot
to defeat no cell to overcome nothing
remains for him and so in a turn that no
one could possibly expect he resolves to
never fight again well for now at least
and so with cell gone everyone heads to
the lookout to get to work Reviving
those who lost their lives trunks gets
his first Revival but the real Focus
here is on Goku as they plead with
shenlong to provide any chance of
Reviving Goku the man himself pipes in
thanks to King Kai once again Goku
mentions something Bulma had said to him
before that it seems like he manages to
attract bad guys and that maybe the
Earth will have a better shot without
him around he's not being a martyr
though as he gets to be himself in the
afterlife keeping his body and fighting
strong guys that exist in that realm but
I will say both of his parting words
really caught my eye and tell a story of
both the Goku he has become and the Goku
we have always known the first quote was
Don't Bring Me Back To Life okay Gohan's
more dependable than I ever was anyway
an open acknowledgment of his personal
weaknesses as a savior and then in the
most Goku way possible he says so that's
it we'll meet again when you die see you
later killing off your main character a
character reader has spent literal years
with at this point is very hard hard not
only to let go of as a writer but also
to do without it feeling utterly
depressing but this final goodbye from
him well just like Krillin says who else
but Goku would be that cheerful even
though he was dead and so it's hard to
feel bad in the face of his infinite
positivity with the Earthlings survived
on a selfless wish made to remove the
bomb from 18 the fighters go their
separate ways convening once more to see
trunks off as he returns to the Future
that he ventured forth from as he leaves
for his epilogue everyone is seen
wearing black armbands a customary Mark
of mourning in Japan no doubt in honor
of the beloved Son Goku and speaking of
that epilogue the final two chapters of
this Arc really do bring everything back
together there is something endlessly
cathartic about seeing trunks return to
his decrepit future and utterly
annihilating those androids which
brought him so much pain before though
trunks may have spent the entire Arc
failing time and time again charging
into situations ill-prepared for what's
to come that is not the case here
disintegrating 18 in one blow and 17-2
Trunks is Thoroughly prepared for this
fight it's a moment he has been
preparing for since this Arc started
years ago and in true trunks fashion he
spares no time putting them down down
the same goes for this timeline cell as
he spends an entire chapter dismantling
cells ignorance and beating the
ever-loving pulp out of him before
extinguishing him entirely trunks's
story is done and given all the hardship
he's been through it's a well-earned
happy ending
huh
we're finally at the end of this bad boy
this Arc is long boy is it long but
again I think I really underestimated
this thing before I started my reread of
it for this video I was genuinely
worried that I wouldn't have very much
to say on it and now here I am roughly
two hours of a video later and there's
honestly a ton of stuff I wanted to gosh
about more thought I had to skip over it
definitely has its detractors especially
among anime viewers but the experience
in the manga is honestly phenomenal so
boy am I thankful that this is the
longest Arc in the series nothing could
possibly be longer than this
aren't I supposed to be interrupted with
a joke to the boo Arc now or something
hello
so I can't use the helmet for the
tournament can can you come up with a
workaround
think you can pull off a do-rag I mean I
can try
so what do you think trunks I think if
I'm honest mom will ground me probably
well if it isn't a great say a man
gracing us with his presence having fun
using our name for your stupid superhero
Vegeta did you take out the
trash like I asked why we have slaves
for that stop calling them slaves fine
interns thank you hey Vegeta you taking
part in the World Martial Arts
Tournament too why so I can beat up a
bunch of weaklings for money I'm already
rich and I've got nothing to prove what
if I was there oh no the voices are back
no I'm real you can cry am I real oh
yeah no I'm real not according to that
court ordered quack actually I hear him
too what the hell heaven actually
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]